Hey There visualpolitik community it
seems like we just started yesterday but
the truth is that this visualpolitik
channel has been here on this platform
on YouTube for more than six years now
during this time we've uploaded more
than 760 videos how crazy is that we've
also seen the launch of visual economic
and our patreon bulletin of course all
of this has been possible thanks to all
of you the more than 1.3 million
subscribers who are part of this
community and who've accompany us day
after day month after month year after
year that is something that believe me
all of the members of this team are very
grateful for well today with this video
we are launching a collaboration that
makes us very excited this is the first
video that visualpolitik has made with
our friends at Harvard International
review we'll leave a few links in the
description so you can get to know them
better we hope you like the result as
much as we do
[Music]
back in 2018 Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
or amlo was elected president of Mexico
and not only that the former mayor of
the country's capital who had already
Run for the presidency in 2006 and 2012.
not only won the presidential elections
but also for the first time since 1988
the president's party also won a
majority in the Senate and the Chamber
of deputies and so the United Mexican
states were almost completely under the
control of amlo and his party the
national regeneration movement or Morena
the victory of amlo who presented
himself as the man of the people put an
end to the political binomial that
dominated Mexican politics for almost 90
years
foreign
1929 and 2000 The Mexican government was
in the hands of the institutional
revolutionary Party The Pri in 2000
Vicente Fox of the National Action Party
managed to break that Monopoly he was
followed by Philippe Calderon another
politician from the same party and it
was only in 2012 that the PRI regained
the government under Enrique Pena Nieto
even so it was not a big change at least
not a change as pronounced as the
victory of amalo and Morena in 2018
because the truth is that the current
Mexican president essentially came to
power with three major promises first
and foremost to be the people's
president the president who would put
the poor first and end the corruption of
the big Elites once and for all we're
talking about guys like for example the
former Governor of Veracruz Javier duate
who allegedly stole almost 3 billion
second to tackle poverty and third to
confront the enormous wave of violence
that the country was suffering
after coming to power amlo suspended the
construction of the New Mexico City
Airport created a new National Guard
suspended the granting of new oil
licenses and renewable energy auctions
and above all launched a huge social
policy package for example he has raised
the minimum wage increased gas and
electricity subsidies and channeled
billions in direct transfers to more
than 10 million Mexicans
milde
ahora satienda todos pero salad
preferential of progress
thus despite a faltering economy and the
fact that the oil company pemex the once
crowned Jewel of the Mexican state is
now on the ropes and that violence
remains out of control the truth is that
amlo has maintained very high approval
ratings basically Lopez obrador is one
of the most popular leaders on the
planet we're talking about approval
ratings between 60 and 70 percent check
it out so in this video we want to focus
on one of the great projects of this
President a great investment with which
he intends to revitalize one of the
poorest regions of the country we are
talking of course about the trend Maya
or Maya train a mammoth work that will
cost close to 20 billion dollars that
will cross the jungle and that was
conceived with the promise of doing
nothing short of transforming Mexico
listen up
historia
[Music]
crossing the jungle
this is Andres Manuel Lopez obrador's
political Diamond the emblematic project
that will shape his legacy a great work
with which the president aspires to
resuscitate one of the poorest regions
of the country economically this project
is so important to the Mexican president
that in 2021 Lopez oprador went so far
as to declare it a matter of National
Security he did so in order to be able
to resume The Works after a court had
suspended them for possible violation of
environmental impact legislation and
then when this decree was declared
unconstitutional amlo again published
another revised decree in which he
insisted on exactly the same thing the
Mayan train is infrastructure that
affects National Security and the public
interest a project whose Direction and
supervision because it affects National
Security falls to the Armed Forces
themselves
amla Issues new decree for
infrastructure Works to be considered
National Security
we are restoring to a procedure
established by law which is to declare
this work of national security for many
reasons because a foreign government U.S
is interfering because money is being
lost from the budget because it is a
priority work because delaying tactics
are being applied and because there is
no quick Justice visual politic viewers
with the length of 1525 kilometers or
948 miles the Mayan train will connect
the states of Quintana Roo Chiapas
Tabasco kenpreche and Yucatan one of the
most important tourist regions in the
country
foreign
this is by far the most ambitious rail
line to be built in Mexico for decades
it will connect the main cities and
tourist regions of the Yucatan Peninsula
from the white sandy beaches of Cancun
to the archaeological remains of the
Tulum as a result the government expects
this train to increase tourism revenues
by 20 and help create more than one
million jobs this would help reduce
poverty in the Yucatan Peninsula a
region where some of the poor Estates in
all of Mexico are located for example in
states such as chipas and Tabasco more
than 50 percent of the population lives
in poverty or extreme poverty but
perhaps the biggest problem is that the
cost of this project has skyrocketed the
initial estimate was around 6.5 billion
dollars then it was announced that it
would slightly exceed 11 billion and now
when there are still many months to go
before the work is due to be completed
they are already talking about 20
billion dollars so it is possible that
the final figure will be even higher
Mexico's Mayan train project will cost
as much as 20 billion dollars 70 percent
over budget the thing is we are not only
talking about amlo's Legacy but also
about one of the most controversial
projects in Mexico and guess what this
is the crucial moment of this video what
will the Maya train really entail what
are the main arguments for and against
this colossal piece of infrastructure
does it really make sense how is it
possible there to train a simple train
has become so controversial well visual
politic viewers let's answer all these
questions let's take a closer look at
the pros and cons the threats and
opportunities of amlo's great dream
lights and shadows
a train from Mexico for Mexico this is
the government's objective and that is
why both the train line and the 42
trains that will operate on it have been
designed and built in the country itself
is
[Music]
actually they were built by the French
company I'll stop so I don't know it
would be better to say that it is a
train sort of from Mexico for Mexico
don't you think about whatever the case
that's just a small curiosity the
important thing is that the government
expects this train to be used by more
than 8 000 Travelers per day more than 3
million passengers each year okay that's
not a very high figure but this rail
line will not only carry passengers but
also Freight and perhaps this is one of
the big key factors in fact if we review
the project and the arguments of those
who have promoted it we can find three
key points the three major arguments the
three major changes that this new train
is expected to produce
foreign
ly tourism is very important for Mexico
and is expected to become much more so
in the coming years both in terms of
domestic and international tourism well
with the arrival of this new railroad
the government expects that the
southeastern states will have a much
more attractive tourist offer and that
this will boost the economy and help
create hundreds of thousands of jobs
over time so basically it's hoped that
this train will set in motion something
of a Mexican railroad gold rush in fact
government estimates speak of no fewer
than one million jobs
turistas
[Music]
pero
solo say
s
cultural
Reggio
song
Las Vegas del mundo but that's not all
secondly amlo argues that this work is
essentially a historical reparation
[Music]
traditionally most of Mexico's wealth
have been concentrated in the capital
city and in the northern states which
are logically the closest to the United
States this has meant that the
infrastructure in the south is typically
underfunded under this bonus the aim of
the Mayan train will be to correct this
historical deficiency and allow many
more businesses and companies to emerge
in this region by more than 13 million
people live this is an act of Justice
because this region has been the most
abandoned which brings us directly to
the third argument supporting this
project commodities
[Music]
foreign
has been sold as a great tourist
attraction but in reality it is first
and foremost a freight train this is the
part that is expected to really make
money for the project however when we
talk about Goods we are mainly talking
about penex the large state-owned oil
company that accounts for 80 of all
cargo moved in the region in other words
the chemix and not tourism will be the
main client of this project
so then where does the controversy arise
I don't know in theory the advantages
seem pretty clear don't you think
boosting tourism overcoming a historic
infrastructure Gap and the possibility
that some of Mexico's poorest states
will now have a backbone for Freight
Transportation which of course could
encourage many companies to relocate to
this region well visual politics if we
have seen three great positives we can
also find three more great disadvantages
three major criticisms that are made of
this Mammoth project and guess what
right with the goods we came across the
first one
foreign you see the problem is that the
Yucatan Peninsula is not very
industrialized and in addition the trend
Maya is not at least for now connected
to the rest of the network in other
words it will basically depend on One
customer pemx and on the return trips
once the goods are delivered the rail
cars and containers may have to be
practically empty this would raise the
price of Transportation considerably and
make it less competitive however by far
the most significant criticisms are the
following two for example do you
remember that the cost of the work has
already gone up to 20 billion dollars
well keep in mind that the Mexican
Institute for competitiveness points out
that this figure is very likely to be
too low they're pointing at more like 25
billion
[Music]
foreign in fact many critics argued that
this enormous amount of money is being
spent to promote tourism in a region
where tourism is already booming we are
talking about such well-known places as
Cancun Puerto Del Carmen and the Riviera
Maya in this way there are many
economists politicians and experts who
point out that investing all this money
in other more local infrastructure in
digital infrastructure or in educational
facilities could give better results in
the long run
and not only that the Mexican State
closes its accounts in the red every
year in 2022 for example they had a
deficit of close to four percent of GDP
and in 2023 they're expected to close
with 3.6 this means that the train will
have to be financed with debt and what
is the problem with that the Mexican
Government is issuing its 10-year debt
at rates of around 8 this means that if
in the end the cost of the project is in
fact 20 billion the Mexican state
devaluations aside could end up having
to pay more than 1.6 billion dollars
each year in interest alone naturally on
top of that there would be the operating
costs and all these factors together is
what explains headlines like this one
the Mayan train will never make a profit
and will always need government
subsidies pan of course supporters of
the project are confident that Freight
will make the train profitable and in
any case they are betting that the
economic activity generated in the
region could far outweigh any concrete
losses for example we're talking about
the 1 million new jobs predicted by the
government will this be possible only
time will tell for now if one thing is
clear is that the numbers are ambitious
be there as it may we have yet to see
the last major criticism a criticism
that has nothing to do with money but
with something else entirely worries are
bound that Mexico's Maya train will
destroy jungle the Mayan train crosses
and connects incredible places we are
talking for instance about the second
largest Mayan jungle in the Americas
second only to the Amazon which is
inhabited by endangered species such as
Jaguars and the Central American Tap
here among others well one third of the
entire route will pass through these
tropical forests for more than 120
kilometers the trend Maya will even pass
through the kalak mul biosphere reserve
one of the largest protected natural
areas in all of Mexico and one of the
most important Mayan archaeological
sites a place that is considered a world
heritage site by UNESCO the indigenous
population does not seem to be very
enthusiastic either among other reasons
perhaps because more than 2 000 families
have been displaced this project is not
planned for us the common people it is a
tourism project that will only benefit
fit the rich and foreigners we who are
the owners of the land will only see it
Go by because there are no planned
resorts for the majority of our
communities open letter from the
indigenous communities of the Yucatan in
2018. well visualpolitik viewers these
are the three great positives and the
three great negatives of one of the
largest infrastructure projects of
recent decades in Mexico
[Music]
foreign
in any case if one thing seems clear it
is not only that the trend Maya is
clearly here to stay but also that it
has the opportunity to be a turning
point for one of the poorest regions of
Mexico of course we've already seen that
there are some drawbacks mitigating
these problems will have to be the goal
of the Mexican Government over the next
few years only time will tell having
said that the questions are now over to
you what do you think of the trend mire
what impression do you have of this plan
leave us your thoughts in the comments
we hope you like this video between
visualpolitik and Harvard International
review as much as we did if so don't
forget to like it thank you all so very
much for watching all the best I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]